So adding colors wouldn't increase latency,
but it would increase the bandwidth.
What bandwidth means is the amount of information
that can be transmitted per unit time,
and it doesn't matter if there is a startup time.
The startup time is the latency, that's how long
it takes to start sending a message across.
That's how long it takes for the start of the message to be received.
The bandwidth is, once you've got some part of the message across,
what's the rate that you can send information.
So this is going to be measured in terms of
units of information divided by units of time.
So bandwidths can be measured in terms of bits per second.
On the internet, this is often measured in Mbps,
which is megabits per second or million bits per second.
I haven't yet explained what a bit is,
and in order to understand information,
it's important to understand what a bit is.